We're finally at the point where you get to do an exercise and do some
programming. To make our ornament, or defensive device to stop the
robo-minotaurs from destroying all things good and just, we need to rotate each
cylinder into position. We have all the data we need for a cylinder. The axis of
rotation, the angle of rotation, and the length of the cylinder. First we create
a cylinder. Using the previously computed cylinder length for its height. Here's
the code that actually sets up the access angle rotation matrix. For the axis
angle rotation function, we need to pass in a normalized axis at an angle in
radiants. This function could normalize the axis itself, just to be safe.
However, for efficiency's sake, it doesn't, so we normalize the axis earlier
here. Next we do an obscure thing. Set matrix auto update to false. This
parameter is true by default. What it means is that, if true then our objects 3D
matrix will be computed from its position, rotation and scale parameters. By
setting it to false we tell 3JS that we are not going to use these parameters.
But rather are going to set the matrix itself directly. And that's exactly what
we do in the next line, where we at long last finally call the matrix rotation
axis method. Giving it our normalized axis and angle. At long last we have added
a cylinder at the proper angle and length to our seam. Now it's your turn to
finish off the rest. Add another three cylinders to complete this object.